you were always one to take a nice
fashion risk I do but I mean I also
would majorly do that for revolve I mean
I think that that they're leading
fashion in Instagram and also in online
shopping and they've made things so
affordable and fun for every woman out
there I'm so proud of them and they're
an Asian run company I mean their owner
is one of the nicest women right so
amazing she is and she shows you how
being a boss can be translated in so
many different ways because she's
fashion-forward she's a mom she's direct
she's compassionate she's caring and she
is direct with what she wants and I love
it when are we getting a clothing line
from you I know we should huh I have to
figure out how to have time to do that I
mean I have a youtube series called
hello honey and I have a podcast and
then I have the real the shot at four in
the morning every day you know and then
I it's just a lot so but I am and I do
I'm a man yeah so you know you want to
give equal time to things that are
important so those are the things that
are important to me right now maybe one
day one day yeah honey because when you
and Jeezy first started dating we had
him over at et and she just was gushing
about you saying that you are such a
wonderful such a good girl what is it
about him that really makes things work
he's the only man I've ever met that is
him
yeah absolutely yeah how serious are
things I mean they're serious enough to
me for me to blush about it I was gonna
say you're getting very giddy
he's so special he's an awesome person
and maybe you can set the record
straight
I was just googling you and did your mom
secretly get married and then you just
recently you did how did that happen she
I recently found out about it which is
like a year and a half ago my mom has
been married for eight years uncle Ted
what up uncle Ted you're not my uncle
anymore but you are in my heart so I
didn't she tell you she didn't tell me
because she's aware that I'm so close to
my dad and she knows that for me the
divorce was hard so for her even though
I was like grown grown she thought that
saying that she had married and moved on
would be hard for me so there was a good
intention to it and also I think she's
called me she's 16 years old she doesn't
owe me any answers to be really honest
with you I want her to be happy she's
always been happy with uncle Ted so hi
uncle Ted / uncle dad
[Music]